ở Xin chào các bạn
độ mixi nhiều cũng kiểu ý anh em
khí hư thứ
nghĩa thừa nhiều người có cái Câu khẩu
hiệu để ngay từ ban đầu thế rất là hai
kiểu một lời chào hoặc là một lời cuối
giống như kiểu gần đây đón xem mà sẽ là
Hùng Bá vô tiền tệ định giá lại tiền cho
nó sẽ luôn nhớ cô cầu câu gì đó
cho tôi thì chẳng có câu khẩu hiệu gì cả
vợ chồng biết được mình nên có một cậu
khẩu hiệu gì bây giờ
ở nhà bạn nhờ mấy ông cứ Đừng gọi tôi
thấy nữa mới qua cái sau tôi có cái gì
đó dùng phút xong rồi lại bảo là thầy
thế này thế kia mệt lắm
anh đợi tôi một tí à
nào ạ
vàng vàng á
ờ ờ đã
Ê mấy ông kia thế nào tôi không biết
được
cứ để cái mác 1960 ở
Âm Nhạc
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay thì ở như mọi khi bảo thì sẽ
là buổi gọi là thư giãn nhẹ nhàng cuối
tuần Tức là mình sẽ học về đoán
tâm sự nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ em một giành
một phải vài phút đầu tâm sự được ạ Ở
hết pin tôi chưa được sạc rồi Tôi thích
ý
à à
Ừ Rồi Alo
khi sex
à à
Sony Cái gì nhỉ gọi lại phải
thế Hả Ờ cái này từng từng đọc bài về
Kenny Kenny cái gì đó chẳng biết phát âm
tên anh này thì anh hài ngoài cái phim
tôi thích gần đây
là cho nó ích thì hồi trước tôi thích
anh đấy Từ phí ma trận rồi nhưng mà trận
là một trong phim gọi là bất hủ gọi ở
trong giờ phim Anh Và Nó nói chung là nó
đánh người xem thứ ba là tôi nếu mà Mấy
ông chồng tình tôi là thực ra là tôi
không thích người người nào khuyên mình
xem một cái gì đó hãy nghe một cái gì đó
sẽ không làm thế đâu nhưng mà tôi đang
đi kiểu đánh giá gốc cá nhân tôi thì à
à à
ở ngoài việc là có rất nhiều phim Mình
thích ra thì thì cái diễn viên nó ảnh
hưởng đến ảnh diễn viên này
ngoài đời thật cũng là con người tốt
nhưng là mình sẽ thích I
ờ ờ
ở đây
ở thẻ tổng tổng tài sản ở 360 triệu đô
này nhưng mà nhìn kiểu
ở trong này chưa ăn mặc giản dị anh ạ ạ
ạ
anh như một người bình thường này
xin hãy
em ngồi với à ngồi với việc ăn xin có
thử thế này vô gia cư
em chụp thuế con gái nhưng mà kiểu không
Không chạy động sạc đấy
Anh
đi xe ô tô buýt thử
ở trung học kiểu một người rất hào phóng
và kiểu dáng cổ cuộc sống kiểu dặn à
Nói chung là không không quan tâm mày
vật chất cái kiểu thế
Ừ nhưng mà tôi nói chung là ok kiểu dáng
là một người tốt và kiểu
ở bảng bảng đồ kiểu dạng là ghi nhận
Dương gì gì đó Nhưng tôi ghét cái câu
cuối của
có một cái Tết này
Ừ thế giới này cần nhiều người như anh
mà Tại sao
tôi ghét câu này
bởi vì câu này là nó là câu kiểu dạng là
Ừ nó đứng yên lòng mang ý tốt mà ý tôi
là kiểu là giống như kiểu dạng mình mình
thì không thay đổi sau khi đọc cái bài
anh đấy mà mình lại kiểu Mong nhiều
người thêm như anh đấy nghĩa nhiều người
chạy bắt chước anh đấy nhiều người sẽ
hiểu khi sinh như anh đấy chứ không phải
là mình Kiểu thế à
đã bán chúng ta cần nhiều người như anh
nghĩa lắm thì chúng ta ở đây nó nó không
thay đổi Chúng ta vẫn thế như chúng ta ở
rất thích thêm nhiều người như thế thế
là xa anh thấy rất là sai với tôi quan
điểm thì ngoài đời tôi có chia sẻ bài
này tôi ghi lại này đừng mong thể có
thêm người như anh ấy mà hãy trở thành
người như thế và tôi thôi à từng đọc cái
cái câu đó là nếu mà xung quanh mấy ông
không có người nào tốt
Ừ thì mấy ông nên trở thành người tốt
thế trong trong những người đấy nếu mà
ông cảm thấy à xung quanh nào chả không
vào trà Không mà tốt cả thì ông lại càng
phải chơi thành người tốt với mãng cầu
để mà kiểu nói chung mà xã hội không đi
xuống chẳng thấy xã hội thì sẽ luôn có
mỗi tối 16 không thể luôn mong tất cả
người xấu thành người tốt
thì không nếu mà một xã hội toàn người
tốt thì chả tốt cả Nói thẳng như thế
ngoại không kẻ xấu làm thì anh hùng
ngoại nhưng mà cái
người tốt thì xã hội và sẽ đi xuống
không ạ Đấy thì chúng ta sẽ lên trở
thành người tốt Còn nếu mà xung quanh
ông Toàn nói xấu tôi chấp nhận ông là
người anh em xung quanh ông Toàn người
tốt rồi Tôi chấp nhận ông thành người
chồng được không Sao ạ
à Còn mỗi khi mà sông quay ôm thấy trái
tốt cả nghĩa là khi mà ông ấy nhận ông
nhận ra được cái điều mà sống anh không
ai tốt thì trứng gà một điều đó là ông
biết phân biệt Thế nào là tốt xấu của
ông lại càng hỏi càng phải biến thành
người tốt để mà chứng minh được hiểu thế
này mới ra tốt này thử
chú ý tao như thế
Thì tôi nghĩ là theo góc nhìn của tôi là
như thế biết mấy ông như thế nào tiếp
theo ừ
à à Reborn
season giá rẻ đúng không Thì
Ừ cái này thì ở đây là khái niệm theo
kiểu là mình tự quy ước thôi chứ không
phải là thằng một có một cái chuẩn nó đó
ở đây cả nó giống ai xin hai cái gì đó
nói chung và mình sẽ tạo ra một cái thư
mục đặt tên là kiểu như thế ở để mà cậu
thì mình hình dung được à cố trong một
vài trường hợp thì nó sẽ xử lý a nói khi
mà xử lý nói lên tấm vào đấy
Ừ ừ thì cái Ôi ở công ty tôi thì dùng cả
hai cái thông Mục đấy và đều làm đều đều
làm kiểu
thứ hai là tôi đang thế công ty tôi nó
không hẳn là chuẩn hóa lắm chứ Có rất
nhiều thư mục rất nhiều cái tên khái
niệm nhưng mà không quy trần đấy cả bởi
vì tôi thấy chuẩn cả là phải tống hết
toàn bộ cái xử lý lấy và bên Vâng ạ
Nhưng ở bên nhờ bên kia lại có đại khá
như thế anh nói chung cả đấy Không có
khái niệm chuẩn ở cả người ông phải có
tự quy ước với nhau thôi
là theo công ty nữa quan trọng theo công
ty nữ
Ừ cái người không biết giận là người dạy
nếu không nghe có Mày về chưa
hai người không biết dặn là người dạy
những người người biết giận mà giận thì
lại là người ngu
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
và đã người biết giận nhưng không giận
thì là người khôn
những mẹo me cũng giỏi đấy chứ
em gái nhớ nó không có cái công ấy ngu
ngốc chỉ có nó đã người không biết giận
là người lạ và người biết dặn nhưng
không giận thì làm cái khôn
Nghĩa là
sau khi mà cuộc đời nó làm tác động xấu
lâu không ạ Nó cũng không thể biết
kiểu dáng không không phải biết được nó
là tác động xấu không để ông cảm thấy
khó chịu thì được ra để ông ngoại hơn
Ngây thơ quá Ông Ngoại hay nói chúng
Ngây thơ quá thì thấy người dạy người ta
chà đạp bóc lột âm hay gì đó mà ông
không hề cảm thấy gì ra thế hơi sai
ngoại
Ừ thế thì ông mấy thôi
không cũng hơi dễ dãi quá thế là hơi bị
dạy đấy Thế còn à
vì thế con người mà
em biết giận nhưng mà người ta lại không
giận người ta khó chịu đấy nhưng người
ta không giận gì cả Ừ thì lại là người
khôn tại sao bởi vì À thì ra À à mình
khi mà
ví dụ điển hình là
tại sao tự nhiên tôi ghi lại cái đêm này
vì à Ngày hôm trước ngày hôm chưa tôi à
họ để bạn đưa bạn về ở khu trung khu
chung cư cao cấp này xong rồi thì tôi có
đi ra ngoài thì lúc vào những đi theo
thẻ của bạn số lúc ra đi ra thì tôi đi
ra thì tự nhiên bảo vệ chặn tôi lại rồi
mà thể đâu mà em ở đây tôi bảo tôi vừa
chào bạn về
du lịch thì thấy của nó thôi kiểu cho
vui
Không không phải là không phải là kiểu
thẻ ra vào của xe đâu nhá ra vào của xe
khác nhé Ngoài cái khu hàng của khuấy
chị xong rồi bảo vệ cái thái độ các thứ
xong rồi bạn là sao không được vào đây
nếu mà không thể nhé vẫn
cậu
đôi nha để trách nhiệm người ta thôi
nhưng mà cái thái độ tôi nghĩa Ôi khác
hay độ với mình
tôi Tôi đã nghĩ trong trường hợp mà có
thể là nhìn mặt mình không phải nhìn mà
tôi dám nói sao nữa không Tôi còn ăn mặc
rất lịch sự nữa tôi mặc quần âu áo sơ mi
trông như thằng đa cấp không phải là
kiểu
ở ngã và nói chung là không phải không
phải có bố nhắc gì cả Có phải là kiểu
giận à
anh nói chung là không phải người à
Trông có vẻ jean đấy có thứ cái ông thái
độ cứng khô luôn à
Ừ
lúc đấy tôi cầu cũng bực lắm rồi ra bực
có những hôm ấy ông mà xem mấy cái kiểu
dạng mà mày cái video trên YouTube để
Ngạn Tik Tok
khi mà mày nhận mình nhân điện phục vụ
Thứ thái độ của mình xong rồi Kiểu mình
sẽ
mình sẽ cẩu quay lại với cậu với một mớ
tiền thằng chủ tịch chẳng đi ô tô quay
lại lại đây mà nếu anh ấy gì gì đó để
trả thù ấy thì cái đấy thì tôi không
nghĩ thế
thôi tôi nghĩ cách ngoài đời thì mình
nên a
ở nhà mình có nên suy nghĩ nhiều vấn đề
kiểu à Người ta khó chịu bực bội mình
bởi vì người ta tự chuốc mình cái bức
của họ thôi mình nên gạt nó đi và mình
nên kiểu
khi tỉnh táo Lại Tôi tôi nghĩ thế cho
tôi cũng khó chịu được đấy nhưng mà tôi
gặp đi được
có nhiều người sẽ ra khó chịu được đấy
cậu
anh Bởi vì bị coi thường tôi dùng từ bị
coi thường với nhìn mặt tôi tôi bảo rồi
là tôi ăn mặc hình sự chẳng qua nhìn mà
tôi có thể chúng non này ông ấy hiểu
rằng thái độ không phải mỗi hôm qua mà
mấy hôm trước nữa thôi cũng bị thấy vài
phát
Anh có thường ai bị thế đôi khi là Cậu
dặn mà nhìn mặt mình non thì mình như
sinh viên đấy họ nghĩ mình có thể không
có tiền nữa Hôm hôm trước vào nhà hàng
chiều ra bão em đã đem gì cậu thứ xong
rồi cháu còn những mình không tiền ngồi
ăn gì vậy đấy có chịu cực kỳ
ờ ờ
anh em vừa rồi tôi đọc lại cái bình luận
thì mày Tôi nghĩ là mấy ông nên đề xuất
là nên mở cái mặt nền gì
vừa dạy học này mở nhạc nền gì
ca nhạc nền gì không ăn bản quyền nữa cơ
chưởng
anh Tuấn hay mở nhạc gì cơ gọi tôi sẽ
được cân nhắc xem
Ê mấy ông cư để sót gà đề xuất qua
discord và có đâu nhé á
Ừ ông này chắc lấy nhắc nên cơ bản của
anh tôi đi vợ Mai
Ừ ok thì nói chung à
Hôm trước mình làm
Lê Ngọc Sơn có thể được nghỉ
nhé
em gõ chấm yan
à à
xem được
này chưa ra được đã tôi bây hôm nay mình
sẽ ra tới ba nhé Thì ta bây giờ mình sẽ
an ninh rồi ông không phải lên mấy cái
trên công ty mình cũng được cục hay
không nó không tốt sẽ tạo mình sẽ tạo
sheet này tôi thường ngày tạo sheet nhìn
từng Minh
anh ơi
em bước ra đi à
ừ ừ
sẽ có u rồi đúng không Hay đi nên ta
a password
nụ hôn
linkpro Bio within
the copy thôi copy đấy nhanh ý
khi ăn cam thu shipper nó sẽ không copy
format chỉ có bia có cái
à à
thế giới thế này tiếp theo mình sẽ có
report
thế này nó là dưới của mấy thằng Hải
luôn bởi vì à Nó có ai đi mấy thằng đấy
mà tại sao mình sẽ có thằng nào nhỉ
Company name a Company trước như thế
Mình phải có vali trước Đợi tí mình sẽ
phải Company trước bởi vì nó Company này
là nói hoài mà nó không anh sẽ có cổng
vợ đi
em đi khách
xuống dưới nhé họ
a tiếp theo mình Có language không ạ
ngôn ngữ
cho tôi nhà quên là thằng ngu de nó con
nữa
em có nên chọn ngôn ngữ nghỉ nên chọn
ngôn ngữ cho người dùng mới biết được
người dùng làm ngôn ngữ gì không nhỉ để
là tìm kiếm
tìm kiếm di đi tìm kiếm CV Tìm kiếm CV ở
CV nó sẽ phải theo ngôn ngữ
Em bé tô mới nhớ vụ đấy Tìm kiếm các nhà
Tuyển dụng ấy các nhà Tuyển dụng sẽ lên
tìm kiếm CV của lập trình viên thì phải
biết được là CV đấy sẽ có ngôn ngữ
thì là người dùng đấy sẽ dùng những ngôn
ngữ gì để có những spg
anh hoặc là
cái CV thôi người dùng có trường hợp nào
có đăng nhiều seri ứng viên
a muội muội tivi một ngôn ngữ
sẽ không ngơi nghỉ
khi ngâm thử nghĩ xem đó là bây giờ một
là cho ứng viên đăng nhiều C vi mỗi CV
lại có thể có một vài ngôn ngữ là sự là
một siêu vi ở Phan Rí ở bác em hiểu thế
hay là lưu lại hầm đuôi ngôn ngữ vào
trong người dùng và
Ê bà cậu khi mà sốt thì sẽ sốt ra người
dùng kèm kéo suy vi của họ
an toàn bộ seri có họ
anh em chọn đi
alo
anh Alo hai mươi mấy ông mà vừa nãy đang
ba mấy xuống hai mới thôi I
ở đâu mày không đâu rồi à
xe máy kéo máy đi ăn về
anh alo mày không rồi
danh alo
có một seri ở đù một Syria
anh không anh không Ô nói trường hợp là
tăng nhiều seri hay không nhưng mà Ừ thì
có thể đang một seri ghi đè lên được có
thể thế nhưng cái đấy tính sau em đã nói
là
đây Nói chung là mày không điểm danh rồi
đúng không Ok
từ ngày tôi hỏi lại cậu ấy nhé Nếu em
cho không đi đâu
em ở nhà thì giờ tôi có hai trường hợp
một này đó là
một ứng viên Ban nhiều cv
em à Có sao không phải chính xác một CV
của một ứng viên
này bác em kiểu ngay ngon hay là một ứng
viên có thể có nhiều kiểu làm nhiều ngôn
ngữ ấy có thể làm nhiều ngôn ngữ
khi sex
ý nghĩa trong trường hợp này nhá Đó là
một ứng viên hoàn toàn thể đăng một cái
CV về file và một CV đang đăng về bác em
ạ Đấy và
thực là tôi cũng ít khi thấy xin cái ứng
viên nào làm biểu tượng 2cv rồi moetv
khoan một CV kiểu bát thì hai thì dễ hơn
đó là một ông viên có thể lúc đầu chọn
sẵn là làm nhiều ngôn ngữ rồi xong rồi
Khi mà nhà sử dụng ẩn lọc Tìm kiếm ứng
viên kẹo ở Hà Nội là xong rồi biết seev
cev của ngôn ngữ ABC ra đấy thì sẽ hiển
thị ra đấy
muốn lưu lại để ứng viên đấy như thế thì
mình sẽ phải lưu lại cả
ở địa chỉ City City lại mình sẽ lưu lại
City nữa
ở
Ừ ừ Nhưng nếu thế thì lại nằm nghỉ nhé
Có rất nhiều thông tin của
khi uống viên
gà đôi khi mấy ông làm kiểu về sau mà
muốn phát sinh thêm cột nhiều cá thối và
mỗi thằng khác nhau mà ông chơi lịch sử
lâu Apple sẽ dễ người tôi chưa chuyên
gia tôi đang chỉ với ông kiểu này thôi
tôi bắt đầu cân nhắc vụ tách sử cái bảng
là rồi
này có thể có thể làm phát ha máy không
à Mệt nhỉ sao đòi Mức lương bao nhiêu
Chắc là vụ đòi Mức lương bao nhiêu thì
chắc là kính sau ờ
Anh có thể làm có thể làm với mốt không
anh đã không đâu nhỉ Chắc chẳng lại lưu
như thế nhỉ
này bản chất là thằng sẽ phải núi hàng
ngày nữa đúng không Mình sẽ
Ừ nó là n nào nữa đúng không
cho nnn
thứ ngày
em nói chuyện nghe nhỉ à
tròn để làm gì nhé có bấm được đâu nhỉ
đi rồi
đấy thì cái này nó sẽ thêm language nữa
và City nữa đây
a city in language đ
à à
Ờ Ờ
mình sẽ có ngôn ngữ đúng không làm cuối
rồi con fix nữa đây để trên cùng lại
được con pic này ký và lưu này đó sau đó
thì mình sẽ có
mày đăng à Mày làm Coffee nêm có vấn đề
ID có file đi nữa file phải nói trước
ô mai
anh Hải chưa phai đi
số điện thoại chưa
- 7 năm trước có thằng nào sinh ở trước
hả
Ừ cái này sai đấy
có một bài đăng chứa nhiều file
em ngồi vợ đi ở đây phải xóa đi nhầm đấy
có một bài đang chứa một file
ừ ừ
như nào nha
em copy hay nè à
thằng language này sau city rồi Sao mà
ngu rô này còn gì em nhà hết rồi nhé bài
đăng vệ sinh ra đây là có sạch Boss
em có bị tất cả đồng hay đúng không
thường là tôi sẽ để mấy cái cột hóa
ngoại đến trên hai chữ cái language ID
này bởi vì nó xuống nhiều thì sẽ tích
cực
Ừ nó đi Sao mất sao bạn dưa này
Ừ anh để kiểu nào của y nó không vì thế
mà đây
à à
ê ê London
ô kê bài tiếp theo mình sẽ có bạn file
bằng file thì mình sẽ có
song song ở đây đó là
Ừ cái bài đăng này
mày đang này nó sẽ à
thì tại sao vì mình sẽ có cả vụ ạ
là người dùng
chị sẽ có ai đi có trách ai đi à
à à
I wish ID này
ở lại hay
có ai đây nó sẽ bao gồm một người dùng
này hay là bài đăng này kiểu như này tôi
muốn làm thế có tao bay là có tí thì như
này đâu như là nỗi khóa ngoại nó rất là
khó mình sẽ không nó khó ngoại đây mình
không làm sao biết nó nói không lại
nhưng mà làm nữa để mà Thì tôi sử dụng
mấy ông về đi thuê ship kiểu để mà kiểu
nó có mối quan hệ đã Hình như thế này
nhé làm chưa À còn chất là thằng này sẽ
queo cả ngoài việc là thằng này nối một
vào đó mình sẽ hoàn thiện theo một cột
nữa một cột khác và giống Cốc hay ở trên
A cái cột hay ở trong bạn report này giờ
hai ờ
Ừ chắc có mỗi report rồi đúng không
report thì sẽ đầy ở
anh sau cái tốt
report a
giữa thằng mày với bài đăng nó một lòng
mình sẽ tạo vào Trung ra nó ấy là tại mà
trung gian sẽ có ai đi này
đấy và
report-id nữa cái ID của cái đứa bị báo
cáo kiểu nó kiểu gì
Nếu mày ông thích đi rõ ra đấy sẽ ra rồi
Hốt này em còn đây sẽ ra
Chị Thơ
tin hot
tố cáo và ạ
chú cá fire nghỉ với cả tố cáo file chả
thế xa tốt thì mình sẽ để cậu y là số
nhiều mình có thể làm được nhiều sao tất
cái đại khái như này mình có lần này bảo
nó vẫn đang nghe nhạc buồn nghe đang
nghe đúng không
thay đổi thêm với diều
anh nhìn có Khó nhìn quá à
Ừ thôi dụng tao lên em nhé
data pay chống nhìn kiểu khác nữa Đỡ
khỏi nhìn gửi ngay nhưng biết là trong
lại dễ
Thế Này Nhá tại chỗ nhé à
ở tuổi trẻ
anh lại phải bưu phải bưu cài reserved
nghĩ à Hôm trước tôi tách cơ mà ạ nhít
hát đi
à à
web môi giới việc làm hôm trước làm cái
này rồi
chị sẽ Clone về sau đó thì ạ tấm vào
trong đấy
cho tôi sẽ nghe
xe Open tour tế
khi sex
a CD này
xe điều hướng chú ra này Cho tôi xin đi
đền A web môi giới việc làm này à
i i
A gọi mình sẽ chạy cái lạnh nữa mà mình
sẽ tạo Lara ở đây
em không bao giờ
Anh không có ý ra ngoài hay sao Nếu mà
làm như này nó sẽ tạo thư mục nào là cái
này
Anh có ở bên trong rồi tôi không biết
được và tạo install này vào trong cái
thư mục đã có cốt được như thế nào thử
nhé
ờ ờ Crystal Palace II ừ ừ
Jack à
Ừ ngày mai là vẫn chưa cho phép với
à à
sư trong kìa được à
cách tạo rồi tôi sẽ copy hết vào trong
những được có gì đâu
dự án
Em đổi tên xem
file này mình sẽ thêm một cái yếm ảnh
hiển thị ở
có tầm bay laptop ai ở đây
à À cơ sở liệu
tạo bằng cái gì cho đẹp đâu Mấy ông thể
đề xuất sau nhé
tôi chưa giảm dậy mà cái đấy tôi có dậy
tôi đã quen đã
à à
à À quên
ờ ờ sữa thiếu mất một cái gì à
Ừ Ok
em mất cái gì mà không lên à
ừ ừ
chưa có ảnh và sao mình sẽ lấy cái ảnh
mà ta bây ở đâu nhỉ Thôi lấy ảnh chính
của oxit đi ừ
ngủ không được
công ty sáng nay
ở đây cần thu được
Ô thế mình sẽ phải à
I speakers
khi mở run Script để tạo ATM
à à
ở nhà ở đây vậy
ở đó có bia
à à
thứ ngày
mở đẹp ạ
cái mở ra đóng đấy với sao đâu nhỉ
nếu có gì mà rồi
cái bên anh sang bên này là được
Xin chào cập nhanh thôi
khi SD mini SD ê
Ừ tao đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
à à
khi mở lên rồi à ngày hình như nó tự
động chạy kia mình rồi chạy kia rồi à
nhỉ nhạc nền em có mai
anh
[âm nhạc]
đút
vào
nhé
ok rồi Nãy
sẽ TP artisan
make
Mason
lần lượt từng bạn thôi các bạn trên cùng
trước bởi vì anh những bản này sẽ có khó
ngoại nối hoa trên người là mình sẽ bài
tập sau mình sẽ ta bảo thích
còn nếu mà Mấy ông làm đầy đủ muốn làm
đầy đủ tính năng thêm sửa xóa thì sẽ là
tạo Mua đồ xong rồi Kiểu à trò chơi ô để
mà tạo máy xin cho các thứ ấy đủ nóng
cách tạo thế cũng được nghỉ
ở Tôi sẽ tạo trước mặt đất như thế đi
Mic màu đỏ
cũng thích
hôn
CD vào đã đi web môi giới
rồi chẳng
số trừ hai tôi chưa
Ok có bạn rồi
mẹ ở trong đời tôi Bây này
Ừ mai xuân Xóa sự hai cái bàn này đi này
mày cứ mảng da hay nó reset password này
và kêu chóp để mà bên sau chóp mà lỗi
thì nó sẽ chạy vào đây rất hay mình có
sẵn bảo sơ thì thích thì mình có thể
dùng nữa mà ra thì chả
có Token này có cần này để ma sau liên
quan việc sử dụng có cân này để mai nó
ra cái Cookie để mình đăng nhập ấy
Coffee Nếu nhớ Coffee không ạ
không dùng Cài à Thế bố ngủ giờ còn lại
của nó
ăn như mây thay liên quan thì phải
không
có ở mắt quốc tế xét nên có nhé nhưng mà
cậu để mình vì sao reset khẩu quên mật ừ
ừ
người vụ bán buôn túi xách
tôi như tôi dừng chỉ chưa nhỉ Tôi từng
chỉ rồi thì bạn
còn pic này mình sẽ có ai đi mà không có
khi và bao lâu thôi sẽ chơi này Đi
kiểu cho sóc
vào kia 200 cả nó không nên uống nick
phải trả nghĩa gì cả vào Alo alo tôi để
hẳn tách hoặc di dân cái gì đó sách thí
sinh
ở công ty của tôi lưu lại cả hai sẽ chọn
tất cả Hi sinh tất cả không quan trọng
đâu Mình xin lỗi mình kiểu cách thôi
có tham stem luôn ngay rằng nó tiếp theo
mình sẽ tạo a
tạo Company
Thảo Linh cho mình xem nhé
không phải ôm mày không Quên mất chờ đợi
tôi chỉ đợi thì
đừng hai mình luôn à sau khi Mã
select2
mềm Express
được lấy kiểu đặt tên công ty không được
chung tránh việc người dùng kiểu nhập và
nhiều công ty quá
Mình sẽ không có tính năng mà cho Ừ khổ
vị à không mình mình sẽ hiểu đã không
hẳn là tạo một tính năng độc lập để mà
tại công ty đâu mà tôi sẽ định làm à
theo kiểu là giống như kiểu thằng này
Facebook mình sẽ cho là người dùng chọn
là đang làm việc tại đâu Xong rồi à cho
người dùng điền cái Company lên đấy xong
rồi mình sẽ tra xong cái bạc Company Và
nếu mà có xuất hiện Có cái có cái thông
tin của Company rồi thì bị ra tôi mà
dùng hoàn toàn để kiểm tra xem à thông
tin này đúng hay không ông ạ Tôi không
biết xác nhận liệu gì nữa ra mình được
thêm cái cột xác nhận được nên xảy ra
bản chất là onme mình không biết xác
nhận kiểu như nào đâu đã phá như thế này
xong rồi à
hoàn toàn là người dùng có thể tự sửa
được để thông tin của Company Tạm thời
như thế còn về sau mà kiểu nó bị làm
nhanh hơn ở kiểu Giận à Có thằng sửa ra
tình nguyện cho mình thấy em cái xác
nhận thông tin công ty ở đúng với sai à
ờ ờ
người khác không hồ lên để phá đâu
khi là đối thủ cạnh tranh
có để mở nhạc bé mà
chi tiết chức
pay nó sẽ lưu lại là cậu ở
ông không xem vui vẻ
nghe Một lúc thấy thời gian cho biết
nhạc gì nữa
nhạc gì sẽ đều đều thôi
Ừ anh tiếng nước chảy nhá
à à
I phone email logo trang trí này thôi em
stem đâu lại là được Tại lúc nào được
Ai Cập nhật lúc nào
Ừ chắc tuần nữa
à à
Ừ hai cái ở nhé
mấy ca nhạc của tôi không biết để tạm
thời tôi chưa mở nhá Cha tôi mời ông cư
cứ nhắn riêng tới nhà nên dành riêng để
tránh bị trôi tin nhắn sau đó tôi sẽ
nghe một loại tôi thể thấy ổn cho tao
hẳn danh sách mở đi Mở lại đấy
ờ ờ
à à
chỉ muốn hai cái giữa này mà toàn bộ
những cái giữ nguyên cứ phải gọi đi Gọi
lại thì PS Xuân Này Tôi từng bảo là ta
sẽ tạo phím tắt làm như lấy mình sẽ vào
bên tao lo này pin rồi xem xe
này với điều kiện là mấy ông Tải cái
cmdr này mới nhất nhé Cái con pic này
cái này rồi chọn Open tôi sẽ Open bye
mở bài
có
nút tắt công cộng ấy xuống tôi sẽ thêm
những cái câu ở đây a sẽ bằng pp ulti
sân nè
anh nghe nhạc bà bây giờ là em là Mike
thằng
mm đi làm mic mua đồ đi kèm theo tất cả
à
anh nói thường nha À mà sẽ bằng pp
attention đ
xe ga tôi toàn ghi rõ ra cơ mm làm AK mà
hay cái gì đó
ở nhà thờ thôi cứ để này đi
mua đồ xong rồi đây xảy ra ông sẽ ghi ở
đây là đô la
Vì sao nha anh thì phải đúng không Bữa
Sao lại xóa bỏ thì chữ à nha Cái Đôla
sao vậy tức là sao tất cả tí mình nhập
cái gì
ở đằng sau cái em em này sẽ bị tống hết
vào Đùa sao đấy
lưu lại cái này rồi mình sẽ tả lại thôi
sẽ restart lại
thế này
ờ ờ
A6 Bây giờ tôi em này xong ngồi đây sẽ
có là language đúng không ạ
Âm Nhạc
Anh
đang quyết
đó chị non tạo phím tắt mình phải như
thế
Ừ đúng rồi đúng là nó nhầm danh cả mua
đồ mà Mai sân thường à thường ở công ty
thường là đi làm dự án lớn thì mày cũng
không bao giờ chúng Ô kìa ngay đâu ông
ông mà ông tạo sẽ tạo bộ đồ riêng và cả
tạo máy Trần riêng nó
không có ghệ ngay
ở nhà cũng không dùng cái kẹo lại nha mm
Tôi thường và thường mà dùng mm để sạc
myrosin mua đồ thì ông lại ít khi tạo
ông có sẵn nó bây rồi mà ông gần như
không tạo ra một lần thôi thầu mít thì
tạo mua đồ ông chị đã tạo máy Trần Thế
mà thỉnh thoảng sửa cơ sở liệu cơ sở dữ
liệu thực tế nó vẫn sửa nhiều nhé do
mình sẽ khi mà sửa thì mình sẽ lại hạn
chế sao cho có ảnh hưởng đến chỗ khác
không ạ
web này
chị sẽ có đây của trang web
nhà mình có ai đi neo đơn
ở trạm Tân à
anh ạ
à cẩn hạt sen món gì cả nhà toàn bộ mấy
cái mình Bây giờ mình làm không có dám
xem tiếp theo other
các axit kệ ngăn chặn à
à à
chị
sẽ có string này
khi nêm
Ừ
vậy thì cũng nhớ hết ở ngoài đó
game Avatar này
tỉnh ở chỗ trống được
rất là đăng ký đâu có điên à Tao đâu
password này
được
em không ăn chặn Ờ người dùng có thể
không Điền mà Linh lại thế Linh này thì
hôm trước bảo là link thì tôi đang định
là là sẽ cho người dùng chỉ nhập một
link đúng ở
một Linh thôi
à à Cậu muốn như thông tin liên hệ nhé
xã hội email rồi mà
số
102 ông nghĩa Nên nhiều lên 01 Linh nó
dễ thì tôi định bắt heo cờ dạng này Đậu
nó là tên miền gì quý Tháp decan lý hiển
thị biểu tượng cho đẹp đi mà định cho
làm như thế cho mồm mẹ thôi mà nên chị
một like cho mình lên rồi tính pro vị
trí rô này là mình sẽ để kiểu in cho
mình sẽ
ý tưởng quy ước proship Em
định liên hệ để vô đi
iPhone là một đi như này
ngày nó không Tôi không ghi hạn
defoe một số kệ cũng chẳng ạ
ờ ờ
sớ
trai thì cho điện ít thôi
a cho lại cân nhắc trước khi Điền Điền
đại quá không ai đọc nữa làm bài thơ ấy
ông ấy position
ăn kẹo chủ đề nghề nghiệp thứ thử đúng
không ạ
tính
ở belem Anna bộ nồi cơm một lần đi Ờ
render à
anh sex ở ở
a cuốn lên nóc nhà
a
City II
à à
ở đây for bắt người chúng chọn
thành phố không nhỉ
Anh không ngại
mặc kệ tính sao Company name a Company
idea
cái đoạn này như tôi đã bảo hôm trước là
mình sẽ copy cài bên A
bên này cho nhanh nhé
em gái xinh
I
for kids
chỉ cần ghi ngắn gọn ngay thôi
A và kompany con voi mi
Vì
sao nói xin lỗi sao Bạn có biết đi hộ
mình để có đi ăn đi chứ nó sẽ nói sao ok
ờ
anh Bởi vì bây giờ có tạm nhiều
có nhiều thằng và có những thằng liên
quan đến nhau rồi là cái thằng ngu tơ
này nó có liên quan đến thằng Công vẫn
yêu tôi sẽ thử chạy My Breath trước đã
trước khi về tí một đống lỗi mình sẽ
chạy A là Mike force a này của tôi bằng
TS xin lỗi chạy nữa
Xong rồi lại thêm cái này nữa thì nó mới
chèn thêm đoạn năm sau lại restore thôi
mình đi kiểu đấy
A Way Back lỗi không tìm thấy tao bay
area ngoài sẵn rồi bây giờ mình sẽ ra
mình có sẵn ra ta bây giờ mình sẽ sửa
lại luôn database cái bên Kyu school
trong Và bây giờ tôi Đúng rồi quên chưa
nhấn mới ôm bắt đầu từ bụi hôm nay là
mình sẽ không dậy à Tôi sẽ không dại cái
bên
cái web kiểu nói chung và web Liên Xô
lại tệ nữa mà tôi nghĩ là tôi có Phan
hàng đầu án này đã thì tôi sẽ liệt kê
toàn bộ thỉnh thoảng một tí một tí so
với ông Nếu hình dung Dù hôm trước tôi
thử nói qua về cái độc lập như thế nếu
ấy không hình dung được nó áp dụng trong
những trường hợp nào cũng mong luôn á
Nhà tôi cứ nghĩ cứ ôm đồ án rồi một phần
là đồ án này của mình cũng nên hoàn
thành nhanh nữa đấy thì mình nhảy sang
đồ ăn khác là beto cốm đồ ăn này rồi đón
liên tục nhá Đấy ạ bây giờ sẽ là những
buổi đoán méo hình cho lắm đấy
ờ ờ
làm lại Nobody
Ừ kệ xóm cái đi anh ấy thế Không nuốt
được một cái bản cũ
xã hội vì à mình không có nghe tôi vẫn ở
xã lạnh rồi
à à
tập 7A
a ghi chú school I
o0o
vì nó có cái này bạn không vấn đề gì cả
này mình sẽ mặc định có con khi nói đến
công phải đi
chị nào nói đến Company nó rồi đấy Ờ
ạ sau đó mình
đây là
a post
à à
a boss
ở bắp cày
hình này nghỉ à
I am first off
cơ chế tạo Facebook này Có ai đi
- Melody
ở trên này à
à à
ở khu vực khác rồi đi là mình sẽ phải
bạn chất Hải à
có vợ đi đi này
cái gì không trót say thồ string này à
ừ ừ
Hai Thôn
Anh nghe nó cứ đề xuất Cái con chết mẹ ạ
em
nhắc nhở trên toàn công Chết dưới tay
còn chết à
khi chết này
City đi chết này danh bị lặp lại
lặp lại khá nhiều mà thường là mấy cái
tỉnh là nó không vừa thay đổi Mình có
thể lưu lại đi của mình cái này lưu lại
bản riêng ấy để đề xuất ra do tiện nhớ
mà một đó thuế Hay là mình sẽ lưu lại ở
con gà ở tôi thôi Em không biết được hả
mình vẫn nên lưu lại bảo
anh Bởi vì em mình sẽ chọn nếu mà theo
lô xích thì khi mà người dùng chọn sẽ là
chọn đá để dùng sẽ chọn cái
a City xóa hết nó sẽ đề xuất ra các tỉnh
đổ ngoạn ngày không nhớ mày kéo ông ạ
đấy
ờ ờ trong chiều mày còn chọn cần suy
nghĩ cơ ngay cả Thế à
thì mình sẽ làm một là dùng cái dân để
mà mình mình tôi có sẵn cái sân để mà
làm cái điều đấy rồi
Hay là mình sẽ lưu lại trong DB cài ID
của ID và nêm ở City và và lý trí là
thằng con rể như thế ai để mà khi mình
chọn nó sẽ kiểu chọn chọn xong rồi nó sẽ
nối ra bên này lại mua cái nó cũng là
một cái cũng được
để tôi thử xem nhé
ừ ừ
Ừ hai mẹ tôi làm đi qua lấy nhé hay thay
vì vi sinh nếu muốn theo kiểu à tôi lưu
thẳng ở trong đạn trong đã tập 72 cậu
Reason
Thì à Thì thì cũng được thôi nha bởi vì
bản chất là mình vẫn nếu mà một nửa
trong đêm mình phải có giận nữa mà mình
phải đọc dưới sân đấy mà lưu ở trong đây
nhờ đây Ý tôi là nó sẽ bị nhược điểm mà
nó bị
nó nó bị nó bị là mình lưu lại thấy cái
cái nên cả trường
thành phố là cái tỉnh nó bằng chữ nó sẽ
nặn hơi nặng một tí hơi nặng một tính
nóng gió
vì mình đưa ID nó sẽ nhẹ hơn
nghe lời nó Điệp lại mà
gặp lại và giá trị Nó gần như không mấy
thay đổi
à à
ở tuổi này
spend a
Có 2 cách để xem
ờ ờ bằng cách cái cách lấy ở trong đã
tới bây Thực ra nó rẽ nóng cho nó gì cả
đưa lý sinh thì có cái mà mà làm thôi
chả Tôi làm em kiểu gì sân cho mấy ông
đi qua cách làm thôi lưu lại trong đấy B
chỉ giống như nhiều cách mình thường hay
làm đấy Tuy nhiên mình lấy hết từ trong
deja thôi mình đổ thì chị thôi không khó
gì cả
ừ ừ
I integer Thực ra là nhiều nhiều
anh nhiều nhớ bên nó muốn kiểu dạng là
nó lưu còn lưu lại nó không muốn bài
đăng của nó là kiểu tiếng tiếng Việt nhớ
không phải tiếng Việt những cái chóp của
nó nó ghi không phải tiếng Việt thứ hai
là cái tiện đồng tiền của nó tương tự
thế nó để là kiểu nin là nghìn đô rồi áp
là nghìn đô đấy Ừ nhưng mà thực ra cũng
kiểu integer nghỉ ở
e ngại ý tôi là cái tiền đó là nghìn đô
trong vậy là Việt Nam đồng ấy bởi vì
trông nó cũng rủ 20 30 triệu không kích
thích bằng 1.000 2.000 Đỗ nhắn thế
những kẻ
mansory này à
khi nghe tôi nghĩa có khi phải lưu lại
thêm một cột cột à Hull City
số tiền tệ
cô Nguyễn Thị Quý ốc
gạo mình chỉ cho chọn là kiểu int a cho
mình mình kiểu để kiểu i5 cho mình gửi
cho mình gửi cho chị được phải đồng tiền
thôi
cho tôi Tôi sẽ chỉ với ông về sau đây
mình sẽ lại inter cho này sẽ là Củ Chi
Đúng không
ở
A và mình sẽ comment ở đây
anh đã chọn tôi comment vì sao mình sẽ
hiểu Nói lại năm thôi Vì sao để tạo Uy 5
cho thoại Nó là kiểu đó một thì sẽ
cho iPhone
hai iPhone A11 thì mình sẽ hiệu Việt Nam
đầu hay nói mình có thể hiểu lại
usb3 mình hiểu là kiểu Đây Rồi em ạ kiêu
kiêu thế
đề nghị chỉ cho Chọn một trong ba loại
đồng nữa được
ờ ờ thậm chí là tôi dậy mấy ông cái này
xong về sau tôi thích thì tôi hẹn dậy
ông thêm về thôi đang làm công ty thì
thứ là máy của em mà không truyền thống
kê về sau tôi có thể dạy với ông là có
thể kết nối Hai tay cùng lúc
22 triệu đã tạo bởi cùng lúc Thực ra hết
2 triệu quản trị cơ sở dữ liệu cùng lúc
tất cả một bên là máy queo một bên
Porsche web nữa bên bố web thì nó những
cái câu truyền thống kê và nhanh hơn rất
nhiều nó tối ưu bên thống kê rất tốt
Nghe tôi hoàn toàn vì sau thế hệ Lò luôn
cả hai thì ăn gì ở đây mình đang lưu
lạnh cái bảng này đúng không So về sau
mình làm thống kê Thế là sao nghĩa là
những ai được
Các bạn cho mình có thể lưu lại mặc định
mình lưu lại là ai bấm vào xem bài đăng
nào thì thì mình sẽ lưu lại vào trong
bên bóp quét hàng ạ Đấy mình có chuyện
với 6 thể làm thêm tính năng thêm đấy
Đấy sau đó thì vì sao tôi sẽ thống kê
Cái đấy là ngã ai ai mà người dùng
thường hay tìm kiếm theo từ khóa nào
chẳng hạn thế tìm kiếm một nữa nào nhiều
đấy Xong rồi lưu lại bên có web thì về
sau làm cũng kết Ok sẽ ra ổn
em là người dùng có khi là không dùng
đâu mà mình ăn mình ngắm rồi
Ờ Ờ
thế à Cách này
anh đi qua mình đấy
à à
cho phép lệ trống
Tôi đang cân nhắc vụ shop đi đấy cho xóm
em tạm bạn đi
I started and này có đấy
bếp này em xem chứ
em ở đâu Cái này mình lên để biết thôi
mình cố định luôn và theo
hình
ảnh chụp ảnh không nhảy theo à thời gian
em tắt date
and Death
inter này
number đ
có bồ này
Ê
status inter này
à à
a Smart mã số sinh ở
Lâu nay bồ cái này Thế mình có thể để
for status là là
anh không ở Nghệ An Trà đá kẹo chưa chưa
duyệt trở nặng thế à và thêm vụ shop
Delete vào xóm mềm mình sẽ à Delete rồi
đấy chờ em chút đi led Xem cầu Nhé Anh
Xóa Delete
ta có
cách tra cứu xem nha Lúc nào
mẹ có một cột xóa mềm
chèn cái thư viện à Có thư viện
smartcable xong rồi nó sẽ tự động tạo
khi mà ông chạy crack hao nào bà thậm
chí Nếu giả sử Chung nó sẽ luôn kiểm tra
hộ ông trong cái bảng đấy nếu mà chung
sẽ lắp nó sẽ tự động tăng thêm uống số
nữa là sự kiểu dự abc bình thường ABC
hãy ngon nhưng mà nó nó có dựa theo Cột
nào nữa giả sử cột hay thù của ông này
còn chốt thay thổ ở trong ạ kết hợp với
phát nữa thì nó có thể tăng lên cái kiểu
một ngay số thứ hai nhà thằng mình sẽ tự
động tăng của ông đấy scrub là gì á
anh mắc là cái hiển thị hiển thị trên đó
tất cả như này cái này tính nó Spark này
cách nhau dầu quá nha kiểu ngay
cái ví dụ kiểu bài đăng tin tức thì mình
không rõ nhất Dân Trí tiếp tục đi
đây là một lúc này
a slack mày slot sẽ cách nhau bởi dấu
cách nhanh nha bạn chất là nó Nó là kiểu
ghi thường đi lại thử thách hồ sau đó để
mà khi mà khi mà tra trên Google thì nó
sẽ nó sẽ ngoài việc là nó tra trên
Google ngoài việc là nó sẽ tìm kiếm theo
thay thù thì đôi khi ông gõ nó tìm kiếm
trong cả anh đúng rồi ngoài việc tìm
kiếm trên này thôi là tìm kiếm trên cả
uro nằm trong Google này có sự bục giảng
chẳng lặng nơi đây
tác dụng slack mà nhìn người dùng nhìn
thì cũng sẽ dễ hình dung được là cây
trang web là gì thay vì ông có mỗi cái
đoạn IV không ạ Nhìn Linh bài báo ấy
đang rồi tôi gửi ông Linh bài báo sẽ
biết được bài báo này đang nói cái gì
đúng không Ông chưa cần phải bấm vào
link không thể đoán được đấy tác dụng
của thuốc là như thế
cái đoạn này Thực ra là tạo đây sẽ tạo
là cái bản trung gian này tiếng tiếng
Anh của nó sẽ gặp hai phát là purpose đ
ô hay vợ tthay bộ và bảo trung gian thì
thì mới không phải tra lại Cách tạo file
word thấy bổ hơn bạn
ý là tôi sẽ
nó không Nhiều nhiều nhiều ạ
Khi bữa trưa tội Vầng cha thở ra nhiều
người quy ước mà cái page table cái file
đấy rồi chúng ra này đôi khi không tạo
mua đồ nó thẳng đới là lao nó sẽ không
tạo mua đồ cho thằng đấy kia có tạo
Mason nhưng mà sẽ không tạo mua đồ
Ừ nhưng mà chính mình như thế đôi khi để
nó sẽ khá phức tạp khi mà thêm thử Xóa
cái gì đó Nhớ là tôi Cứ theo thằng nào
đeo trước bạn nha rồi tí về sau tôi sẽ
chỉ nhược điểm cái việc à Tôi là xóa
nhập Tôi sẽ chỉ nhược điểm của việc là
không Nếu mà không tạo mô đồ thì nó sẽ
có những cái vấn đề gì không ạ
Ê thằng trung gian này thì thường nó lưu
lại à
Em chúc gia này chỉ được phép nên lưu
lại 2 2 cột 2 cột ido Nếu là thằng trung
gian là trung gian giữa cả ba thằng Hà
Ba cụt rồi Thằng này Trung ra giữa xe
ngày thằng này thằng kia ạ và vi phạm
quy tắc là thằng rally thì cái thằng tay
vợt này nó khó mà khó mà kiểu
không Tạm màu đó còn hiện tại thì nó rõ
ràng là chị Hai
cho hai thằng trung gian thì tôi nghĩa
vẫn vẫn làm tạo được hai lại không phải
bibus nhé Anh có thể viber nó cột ID rồi
ông Tăng ngay nó đúng là nó là lưu lại
thông tin cả hai hằng nhưng mà thằng này
thần độc lập của thằng này thì nó lại
thằng Vios Vios anh mình sẽ không tạo
mua đồ riêng là nó ấy cứ Hình dung là
Tạm thời như thế Tôi sẽ tạo à Mai xin
cho thằng này thôi
ừ ừ
a minor Chanel
I read faq
I know which I
anh ạ
lười cơ có Pocket Bây giờ cậu particular
purpose
Facebook
có để tạm I've seen My xin cho thằng
find many to many đ
anh ạ
ai đi hai thằng trung gian nha
truy vấn Make My này nó nhanh không ạ
chợ hoa cài hình Nhật - purpose rộng ra
vậy Thằng này nó hỗ trợ vậy không ngờ nó
vụ này lắm
đọc czech
language Mình sẽ lưu lại
ông hoàng kỳ hai hàng thôi
à à
em gái
quen quen quen
I love fake ID thì mình lại không làm
được điều đấy
rồi ok đi đây mình sẽ nối một là uzair
hay là phốt nhà mình sẽ phải tạm theo
kiểu bình thường
bố mẹ tôi tra lại chỗ
nhờ đăng kí nha Fiorentina
ta kiểu
là cột thôi không nói khoa ngoại
tiếp theo
a language
Ừ cái này thì lại nói khóa mạng như bình
thường được
a language ID
à à
khi họ rồi
a tiếp theo là
ở hai cột này phải là khóa chính thì
mình sẽ có là thấy bồ
I find family ngay à
Ô kìa không quanh đây thôi nó thì mình
sẽ là Mạc nó nhiều khóa chính sẽ là Oh
jak Doo
số bệnh như này đó lấy hiểu là 2 2 cột
này của nó khá chính ok chưa tiếp theo
hai
đây thì thực ra mình nên để Indo cho về
sau có thể có thể
anh nhiều hơn
mình sẽ i5 mà đoạn này đi năm
tiếp theo file
Khi bữa đi
ai đi này
a-class khẩu cho cắt cổ mày
Are you ready
số người dùng về sau có cho xóa file bể
mụn ẩn ẩn file CV đi
bí ẩn file DVD có chắc Xóa hẳn ẩn gì nhỉ
ứng cử viên muốn ẩn file CV của mình đi
khỏi xóm đi ừ
à à
Ừ giời đi này
a What ID này
ở
nhà thằng hàng cho phép Nepal
à à
khi nuôi bồ này có nhớ hôm nay phải để
đến trước
khi họ tiếp theo là
xe tải may của thằng hả Rồi cảnh báo tôi
không Tôi để xuống cuối nó báo lỗi ấy à
exe
không không lấy miễn phí để
anh Linh nhảy
anh không bị trống
ở lại inter cho hay thôi
tuổi gì tình báo nhiều thế
Vì sao mày report
à à
giờ này
gần cuối lúc nào chả có có có à
Anh ấy buồn à
ở đây tôi sẽ bắt chước thằng kia là mình
sẽ
mình sẽ cậu
em có một cột cho anh sai rồi nha để nối
cũng chẳng để nối nó là xong và kiểu cụ
để thôi cũng không nói gì cả
à à
Sao không bảo ông đừng tự an ủi bản thân
nữa
Ê status
thì ra mấy ông có thể để đây inter rồi
cá nhiều quá mày không thể để more được
về các bạn thì các bạn không lên đến hạn
cho inter tận 2 tỷ mà để hải ngoại không
thể small được
em có small to ơn anh nhé
em
thậm chí phía sau nhiều nhiều chỗ mày
không có hệ ghi Nếu không có thể ghi các
bạn suy nghĩ Hồi trưa tôi tổng bị nói vụ
đấy Đó là mấy ông ghi lại sinh kiểu ngày
mà tệ 255 ký tự được ra nó cũng quá
nhiều mày không Có thể cậu giúp gọn nó
bị được chỉ phe được 50 ký tự thôi như
này chẳng hạn đấy Tôi đang cứ để mặc
định kiểu như này cho mấy ông dễ chứ ra
về sau à nhiều nơi ở sẽ rút gọn bớt đi
nhưng mà nó cũng sẽ nhược điểm như tội
từng nói đó là
nếu về sau muốn tăng lên đấy nó trông bé
ông Hạn chế sửa ở cái cột và đang tồn
tại
xe tải ông thêm cột mới thì không sao
nhưng ông sửa cột cũ thì nó sẽ nó có vấn
đề Đối với thằng ép máy Ware thì khi mà
sửa cột là nó sẽ nó sẽ thêm cột và nó sẽ
update từ cột cũ sang cột mới thành ra
là Nếu bả của ông đang có rất nhiều dữ
liệu 2 triệu hai ba triệu Bạn ghi em ạ
Con sẽ làm đâu chết luôn cái đôi tay của
ông treo luôn nó cũng bởi không thì lấy
hàng ra là
mấy ông đôi khi không nên tiết kiệm quá
Nếu không không ngừng với cô trước tôi
thấy em định Hồi trước đấy công ty rồi
tự nhiên Chả hiểu anh nào tự nhiên để
cái snack nói chị giới hạn 32 ký tự do
về sau tăng đây là 60 tư ạ chết luôn đã
bây nửa tiếng đồng hồ vì chỉ là nữa cập
nhật giới hạn từ 32 thành 64 ngày cỡ thế
nghĩa là nếu không phải Ông cẩn thận thì
mấy ông có thể cho nó dư ra cũng không
sao cả về sau dữ liệu của một cái bẫy
đương nhiên là đương nhà mình rút gọn
được chỗ nào rút gọn nhưng còn những chỗ
Anh cũng vậy theo kinh nghiệm mình không
nên chụp này không nên rút gọn này ạ đấy
Âm Nhạc nói chung à Nó hơi bị đau đầu
lợn đấy không biết được chỗ nào nên rút
gọn cơ rút gọn rút gọn quá không tốt đối
ngoại này
Ừ OK Xong hết rồi nữa thôi chị chạy Mai
Nói cho Minecraft hết à Đúng rồi tôi
mình cho tạo xích đơ tao chỉ đờ khi sử
thời gian
nhà ở
ông ấy cái vụ ship đâu thì như hôm trước
mày Ông thấy là
Em yêu anh xót mà không thấy thì tôi
hoàn toàn hệ tạo cái ví dụ là tạo mẫu ở
đây nhá sẽ tạo cái chỗ Company như thế
này sang ạ Thế tao ở đây là
với
Anh có giận ai đi tượng tăng rồi đúng
không Mày đó giết đấy
Xong rồi đúng không
có ai đúng không xong rồi à
a nhớ nói có hỗ trợ cả language ngôn ngữ
thứ gì đó vợ nhiều lắm
ở Xuân này
a web
khu di tích
ở đây là cái gì nhỉ
Master này
a ly này tách Hutech á
ở đại hội chợ nhỏ
a
HTML or Android
anh không biết tin là hl đã đề ra sẽ là
gì
A Z
nhé Tôi sẽ là lâu lum này cho Word từ
bao nhiêu bao nhiêu ký tự ở được
ừ ừ
Anh định nói ba ký tự
Thôi luôn Face cô ấy về sau thích đã ký
kết lên nó tránh lỗi
ờ ờ
như ngày đúng không cho tao thì mày ông
vào bên a big sister này không sẽ gọi
kiểu dạng là như thế này để Kris đúng
không
ở
gần nhà ông sẽ độ Cái này là language
đúng không
chạy thử nhé
lại 10
ở sông ngòi tôi chạy là Minecraft này
kèm theo mà à
a xít nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ hai cái này phải đấy thấy ông lúc thì
hai chị hai cái dấu lúc một cái cái thật
Ý bạn nói gì
cô tử Phú Thọ
a Huy Huy
Ô hay nhỉ
cài đặt thông tin sai gì à
em biết đường sai khi mà tặng tao bây ạ
ở Mỹ không đi ô
em này size gì vậy
à à
em chuyển Android
bóng đá
em ở đâu Tôi chạy nó nguy cơ mà thôi có
chạy mấy thằng kia không nhỉ ở trạm bé
ngoài đâu
anh làm sao để báo lỗi mấy ngày được
nghỉ Adele trong user
ca nhạc thử Xóa này nhá dù sai đi
anh chạy độc lập bọ xít trước giả xem bị
lỗi gì không
anh gọi thêm sheet lại bị chết chết gì
đó chạy đang có ích này
ờ ờ
like Factory bị vấn đề
Ơ hay
à à
Pika Story
a new Factory free of Model
hơi lạ
em xem lại xem Hãy database bình tạo nào
có mỗi bột nêm với chứ nhỉ à
ở Hà Nội nhỉ Hay là do tên của
xanh
em gái tôi dùng để mô hình cho em mà
À rồi rồi hiểu hiểu hiểu mất toàn bộ nhé
một cái xin lỗi lỗi tội lỗi tối thôi ơi
chưa đọc kỹ cái Hàn đấy
thôi hình tôi nhiều không bầm như có
cách chạy xì thôi đấy không cần nói phét
liên tục về đâu Anh ở
BBC đấy
à à Ừ thì chạy Cụ thể một thằng đấy
ờ ờ
lại cái Hằng đang web này mình sẽ thêm
topic a
a stem
Ê bà Băng full ra mình sẽ không có cột
nữa rồi tất ở phí thấp thì mình mới chạy
được Glass
ở đùi và thử xem nhé
Ừ nó là được ok rồi không ạ ạ
a tiếp theo tôi tạm thời chưa làm chưa
chừa nhắc thành cái vụ ạ tạo bản khác mà
tôi sẽ có một cái bảng nữa Liên quan
không wesley
ờ ờ
ở mỗi bảng này liên quan language phải
bằng lá dừa nhé Còn tôi đi nè cho tôi
phải tặng Company Sau đó tôi sẽ có
một thằng liên quan Company News
ừ ừ cho tôi tại có mấy đi xong rồi Loser
Tôi đang muốn làm ở đấy bài toán là gì
để mà tôi muốn khách hàng này
cho phép cài companyid ở trong này không
muốn Face đâu đấy
Cô mang quýt tặng kệ đã mình sẽ tạo luôn
cả Company đã cả
ờ ờ
đây lại thì đợi gì
anh Coffee hiện này nha nó bị này
I am chọn
là cái cô ấy
Ừ vậy đó xin làm gì đó
à Xong rồi Đồ logic II
ờ ờ
khi sex
a Company của At least a
a web
web 1 code
mã số riêng rồi nhé chết last name card
number đã bị đình number secondary Atlas
chính là cái Everest hay mà tôi bảo mày
ông ai nhìn chưa
này rồi
Ừ
Sting Deadliest này
ca nhạc ngọn núi xếp ờ
em gà Cái này bị ngược điện nếu mà làm
như này xong rồi về sau mấy ông ma Pink
xanh cái data data base
cái cái
Vision thành phố và tỉnh thành phố của
hãng Việt Nam nó không ra Vì rõ ràng đây
đang tỉnh thành phố nước ngoài
ờ ờ
the City
cho nó hiểu cho nhé bây giờ ông phải
Faker Chắc là hình như có phép cờ mấy
ông thích đóng góp trong cái sách Hải có
ấy nhá bản chất con bò Suốt này
Nghe câu này
bản Việt Nam Đấy đấy à
chú chó
em
có có cả
các bạn
em có cậu với Sơn á được có lại
cho tôi biết là kiểu gì cũng có một ông
đó chấp nhận và Lê đóng góp
được cái tên Martin đóng góp vào sướng
mà
Ừ thế thì mình chỉ được đồ ngôn ngữ rồi
mình sẽ đổ ngôn ngữ ở đâu nhỉ À
khi sex
thật là không dùng cái này đâu Ờ ờ
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí nha
cho tôi À cái thằng nào cài sẵn không có
cái nào phi cơ này nó không phải là xong
vector thằng hacker kia để mà có thể hỗ
trợ vụ quá
Ừ Ok xin
are you
if you are you can fix đầu thế giới với
sân nhà
ừ ừ
à à
I Fall
are you despite Factory speakers
I have this page or Chẳng có gì cả
Vì sao
anh phi cơ ngày nằm trong
quần Factory store Tôi không chắc vụ phi
cơ này nó là cái thư viện này nghe không
có lô cửa gỗ là đi trên đấy đâu
anh
IELTS cơ này à
và Vậy à
Aura ngay được mà
I love curl mình áp tròng chị nào xem
em không thích áp nghề xong à
em không thích áp
được
thì mình sẽ là Vi ghen nha mày bạn trẻ
nha
để tối anh thử thử thì biết không
Ừ chị xinh xinh để chinh phục à
e3z có canxi thôi chị ạ
ừ ừ
tra có Zip Code trong trường hợp này nó
postcode à
phone đang bị báo lỗi cái này chả liên
quan đến nay
cho người dùng
anh có xin nghỉ Vì sao
anh nói phone number ngay trên này phone
number
à à
Em email
ờ ờ vậy Sáng I miss u
Ừ mẹ ul Mp3 ok thử nhỉ
Anh bảo lỗi ạ
mà
à à inmate
anh nữa à quên mất những trước mình gọi
cái này mình sẽ lại cho đề hàm
Ok rồi
nhận kệ không Có chẳng
ờ ờ
thì mình sẽ thôi
anh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh Tôi
cho làm xong hết á thì không phải để ý
kỹ lại là bạn của mình có nhiều cột vừa
nãy mình cho cách nung nóng ạ bây giờ
xem lại ngủ giờ nha Tôi muốn cho vài cột
nó có thể Nhung cơ chúng về của nạn điên
đầy đủ như thế đâu
Nó hiểu đi rồi không
biết không anh trai được không
nó phải duy nhất
à à
a fool in 50 posts
nghỉ cho vừa múa lân tự quyết định kiểu
là con núi không
ừ ừ
tạm thời cho một vài người có thể được
em ngút ngàn cho nó hay ngon Faker kiểu
có dữ liệu hết thì trong mà không vui
rồi Ở thì nó không đúng lắm không thực
tế nên sẽ là Company không ạ Company à
a Company Mình hãy nhớ không có không
không có cột ở
đi thăm stem bỏ đi
anh nói chạy Nếu mà chạy thế này nó sẽ
chạy lại cái language tắt nữa Nhưng thôi
kệ
anh đi phải không em
à à
Ai
Cập nhật trẻ em
a Building năm bội thu
sự
sáng tạo này em có live stream
à à
khi sex
Ừ biết rồi
biết rồi
mục
tiêu City
À hôm nay City giống nhau
không có một số cái đúng không
ăn
uống hợp lý
áo bị sữa đúng cột không được phép Mun
Ok đình Tống ở cột nào đâu Cái luôn được
nghỉ à
tư vấn đi à ờ ờ chẳng có thể nào được em
luôn
cách đánh 10 ngón ở đâu á the first
single và nhắn tin với gái em sẽ đánh
được mới món cho dễ
Ừ ok
Ừ nó Thu Nga
nhân xưng ở ngoài luôn nhỏ tôi không
thích thế thôi sẽ phải sửa lại cái vụ
nêm
a person
rồi
I first met name
Nó bao gồm vật hay thô
ở chùa nó bao gồm thay đồ rồi không
thích thế sẽ last name first name thôi
sẽ hay hơn
này sao nói trận với cách làm cái đúng
không ạ xong rồi như này à
ừ ừ
Có ai đi tên các cụ đây cả À
à à
phần mềm nhà trắng ạ
anh hoặc
ê ê
xóa Dũng điệu đi gì vậy
nào
à nhầm
ở Madrid II máy quét này
em xin anh
à à
khi sex
Ừ ông kia vừa nãy giờ tôi đúng không có
đâu
I my Last Ship lại
Em
về chưa
ca sĩ xinh nói
cái đít chích đúng nó vẫn đi làm à
Ừ Ừ nếu mình làm kiểu u khi tách kiểu
ngay
cho địa chỉ Mình sẽ chỉ có nên à Chị
mình lên là
nêm với á tụt number thôi Chị sẽ thế
à à
khi sex
em nó Ok ngon rồi đấy
gì ngon ngon ngon
đây
nhưng mà nếu thế này City canxi
thế này thì ra hơi sai và lôgic thì rõ
ràng là
căn chuyện này gọi mình mình đang làm
cái cậu quên đi này có thể nhiều quốc
gia cho đầu mũi Việt Nam đâu Không nói
tôi lỗi tôi
cho nên này đêm này cũng sai này nên lại
lẽ là phải Company lên đây có không có
đi lên rồi lấy sự cái person nêm Company
Vậy ai có Company mà
ừ ừ
bây giờ Factory mới đúng
Hà Nội Tôi
Ê
bà đây sẽ ra công ty gọi đến
Ừ
mình đi thôi như thế này
Ừ ừ
thế thì tôi không thể ghi đè được xong
cái á con fix này rồi
chị sẽ không đi để trong con fix này
em sửa lại cái này enough
the web
Ê bà tôi sẽ phải ghi đầy thủ công nghệ
trong Company nó thoải mái với kiểu quốc
gia nào được à
à à
Vì sao được ở sai sai Nếu mà bây giờ
random local
à à
khi Naruto kết để mà nó hiển thị ra đây
ra hơi khó đấy khó làm thế rồi
Wifi này tôi theo tôi đang hiểu thì nó
là ấn triện nó Định nghĩa một lần cái
thằng phi cơ Để mình cứ sửa đi sửa lại
hình cái cơ mà tạo ra thành nhiều quốc
gia được hơi khó
A
gọi hiện định select options để bán kiểu
làm cái gì để mà theo có ra và hơi khó
thôi chắc là tôi tạm để tiếng Việt nha
vi phạm quốc gia Việt Nam đây sửa lại đi
tính sao mình đang làm tết test mà
ờ ờ em mình cứ để nó là vi e này
Ê bà Hồ
bộ phim hài countries lịch sử Việt Nam
cho phép mà
ở Việt Nam nữa song
tra những kiểu Yêu Thương OK
em trả lại phút cuối
anh đi
Ừ ok chưa ổn rồi đấy tiếp theo à
à à
chị xem bên anh nhỉ ô ồ tôi tôi Company
rồi cảm ơn đi rồi mình sẽ bên A
bây giờ một giờ để mà tôi muốn làm về
khóa ngoại xong lại có quân y là tôi sẽ
chịu mày ông cách mình làm hai khóa
ngoại nó như thế nào phá hoại hai khóa
lại mà kiểu dạng ạ trong một vài trường
hợp thì mình dùng Faker hay dùng cái
Factory định nghĩa như này hay là mình
sẽ ghi Thảo trong shipper tí mình sẽ do
tôi sẽ tạo hẳn 10.000 u rơi em ạ Nhưng
mấy ông sẽ đo thời gian thời gian cậu
chạy cái file này bao lâu nó nhưng dùng
ạ này ờ
Anh chúc em và muốn em ở bàn phím lắm em
này
I
was it này
thế này
Ừ cái này ra
ờ ờ
à à
đây dễ sửa ấn vào đây sửa nhanh này
email này
bắt buộc à Nhớ là phải nó có hội chợ
password
à à
được mình sẽ chơi kiểu gì
ừ ừ
trách này giờ bị chơi kiểu à
ờ ờ
các thứ I have made cái thứ mà thôi kệ
kệ
a number
Ê Linh Linh á
anh Linh ảnh như mình đã phải chống vậy
về vụ Linh lùn sau đây cái vụ này mình
sẽ tạo rô pro mình sẽ tạo à
bộ phim là cuộn
em
ở đâu Coffee ở tỉnh thành nào ạ
ờ ờ
bộ bát mã hóa thì mấy ổng có dịch được
đâu À thế rô này mình sẽ là tạo cái năm
sau đó mình sẽ ghi trong này ra thế mình
sẽ là
mấy năm
hồ sơ
à à
viện ai năm
Alo
vtv8 này có sẽ đi làm mà
ý
nói sở này
à Tôi đang dùng là tao mình ở
ừ ừ
chị sẽ ra Bắc Ninh
a constant
Ý là mình sẽ là mình quy ước nó là những
gì nhỉ
Ừ thì mình chưa ghi ở trong này mình
chưa ghi alo cho mày mình sẽ là onme này
họ Đậu Nga trở lại Nam in cho ạ
Em không nhớ anh không
Em 12 cái gì đó
có gì
em ở cuối tròn và giọt
à mình mình đi phẫu thằng này thì nhé
phố tháng ngày làm 11 thì mình sẽ hiểu
là một là là kiểu à
à à
Cho tôi xem lại cái mình bắt về bên à
Ocean này amply
anh em Lincoln đá kiểu người Ông Tuyền
ngoại thư cân
thế này à
ở chỗ cam à
có một lại ngày amin là không này
Ê bà hết rồi Sự thật rồi chẳng có hai
đối tượng kiểu ngay sau đó thì mình sẽ
chạy Faker này à
như thế này sau đó gì gọi u xơ
ạ sau đó đi apogee lấy về nhỏ ghét lá
luôn nha này lấy cái toàn bộ xong rồi
bạn Bun lại một cách cách thì mình có
thể chơi hả sư cái
Hà merandom cũng được là tôi nghĩa cách
cài cho nó bắt chước phi cơ được nó
trước khi cơ đại thả mình xuống FA công
nhân thường là mấy công nghệ cho A
random ngã sau
Ừ ông xã có đi nhau mà à
Anh ấy chạy vậy Mua trong hai cách đó
ngoài những cái này nó hợp ngon ở điểm
hơn là nó đùa mà cả cho clip trên không
phải mỗi Android ngon hơn thì phải
ờ ờ
a tiếp theo Bio
xe máy ô để tách đúng không
Vì vậy bạn mỗi đoạn tách cả đó để sử
Wendy Nhưng mà như vậy Nãy tôi bảo tôi
muốn có thằng ghi K50 mình sẽ 4 lần đúng
không ạ
phần listen có sơn thì cái kompany vừa
rồi còn rất là hay họ cố gắng giúp 2
thôi ấy này nè
ở đâu phải khổ à
nhà máy XANH tả
ở nam giới cũng sẽ cố tôi
Anh dám chắc không ai biết đâu Ờ
tạo bên Excel
I fall xinh đấy
là gì nhỉ
anh lên đô lên đồ mình sẽ cho Baron quá
City City City ở
a Company ID đây cái đoạn Company AD này
thì à
Em chưa có nhiều cách một mà ông gọi đến
kiểu giọng mà
ông đang ôm nay ở đây hai Ông Bà mình
sống gọi đến
Vì sao ạ
ừ ừ
cho tôi lần cho tôi làm thì sẽ làm với
thưởng ai làm sẽ là như thế này
ê ê
à à
Rồi inbody Model
khi
in ảnh sau đó đi à mình sẽ ghét để lấy
ca trù trước nó ra mình thì lại đi Thôi
đợi ông nói cho ông có xem mẫu của thằng
ngày trước lại nhá Tôi cho mấy ông sẽ
mẫu nó chữa đã
Ừ cái vụ quà rồi
mã số ID chả có
khi sex
ừ ừ
ở đây nó còn gọi Hiệp cậu dutifully ở
nhà coi
nhà tôi sẽ làm hai cậu như này cho mấy
ông
ở
trên đấy cô đã đi đâu nha rồi lấy ngẫu
nhiên ở đây thì mình sẽ
Anh nhìn thấy cháu cho đoàn dus Jadoo
như thế này lấy ngẫu nhiên này thêm một
cách đây một cách
ở nhà cách cách này là ông cứ mỗi lần
ông chẳng qua đây rất nhiều câu truy vấn
sẽ thành ra nó sẽ ra trận cho mấy ông
thử
chị xem aras anh này nếu mà in ra Dual
Model thì không thể phát hiện thấy thằng
đầu tiên và Peru lấy cái cột ID đầu tiên
này
hình dung đã
mình sẽ tạo ra ozer này đúng không
Mình tạm 10.000 đê
a cho bé ông sẽ thấy câu hỏi chi gần nó
lâu nha
khi quét là oxit này chạy
à à
ô ồ
à À cái này
em không lấy được random à lên
domelement em phải đây là ghét
ừ ừ
nữa mình quyền của anh xin lỗi lỗi tôi
nói tôi anh chỉ cần lấy một cái đi Ngay
sau ok rồi Cái này à
hình như không bấm đâu vụ ship
có phải đúng không
giờ thay vì tôi làm như thế này hay vì
tôi làm gì đấy nó sẽ chỉ mấy ông cách
làm
Ừ tôi sẽ ghi ở trong xích đâu tôi sẽ bắt
chước này thì không xin được
à à
3 cách chế tạo xi tốn
Anh không dùng wifi chỗ anh ạ
ứng dụng đã Tuổi Trẻ
à à
các axit no
I gotta này
anh không
đúng rồi để một cái data mình sẽ có một
cái Android chứa rất nhiều với tay mà
Mình sẽ khi sốt cùng một lúc hàng fake
cơ doris cơ này tôi sẽ có đưa Faker
bằng new hacker này à
à à
ô tô
á Vừa nãy Ông kia gợi ý chúng ta đã có
một thằng hacker có thể gọi được đến
anh không biết đấy Thằng nào thôi
à à
Ừ
tra lại cái vụ hacker xong
à à
ở phòng máy tính gọi cho ai
ở ngã đây có thể yêu được thoại
à à
ạ sau đó đi toàn bộ hẳn Dora hacker này
sẽ sửa lại thành
cà phê câu này à
bí quyết ngay đã à
như thế chẳng cần lưu bạn này chỉ cần
như ai thôi
à à
ở đó đồ thay đổi lại đổi
tĩnh
vì vậy mẹ không cần chuyển Ok lại như
thế này gọi yêu Ok rồi ta như này đúng
không Mình sẽ Ford Ford đây chạy vòng
lặp Đây là gọi y = 1 You Lie nụ hôn bằng
10.000
anh phi công cộng nhớ bằng lái phone
cho mình sẽ tấm
trong tháng đây này
chuyển vào như này chuyển phút đẩy vào
như thế này ơ cái thằng này Tôi đã sửa
lại Bởi vì truy vấn như này mùa 10.000
lần câu truy vấn như này Thế nó rất là
nặng em tôi sẽ làm như sau sẽ
có tiền mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ tất cả
Company ra như thế này bằng
mình sẽ ăn đu model introduced model
hiện nay
anh
chẳng cần và domodal két lấy ra thôi mà
ghét một ai đi ra chỗ em ạ ngay
gần mà tôi sẽ dùng một blog nhà để lấy
ra một cột à
A Gọi lắc lại xong mà to Write để biến
nó thành mạng à
anh
mắc này cả giữa hai nó kết hợp với việc
và snack vừa rồi bị nói mạng được
Nghe
ca nhạc à
anh ấy mỗi cột này một đáy biển nó thành
mạng
nó lên mạng à
sửa lại đây là Random
Nghe danh sách tất cả ai đi đấy nhá
bộ Disney like không có gì không trùng
cháu đi sân này cả
rồi mình sẽ
Urê ở đây vì bản chất ở đây mình không
cần kích hoạt cái cái even cái không cần
ở trại clip và mình yêu rất nhiều thằng
cậu lúc mình sẽ chạy dài ít thôi như này
à
khi mình không cần mất công class làm gì
cả nghe tốc độ nóng sẽ nhanh hơn rất
nhiều mà không có khởi tạo đối tượng nó
không có kiểu lắng nghe sự kiện gì cả
đấy
ê đờ tôi chạy lại thì ông sẽ thấy tốc độ
nó nhanh nha thử nha
quên không không nhanh hơn được nỗi đã
đã gọi thì bí thư ra xin lỗi gì lỗi thì
mình sẽ gọi lại bên này
Anh ở đít à
được
làm nào sao thì nhanh được không ạ
em ăn ít hoặc đền ah Ooh Transit này
đúng không
ở LX
à à
ở đâu mình anh nhanh
em heo Chào anh anh lỗi rồi Nhiều nóng
vẫn nhanh ờ
thằng ship cả ngày nghỉ tí nhận được
tính à
xin lỗi
ô ồ bị lớn quá cái này liên quan đấy hội
Xin chào hôm trước tôi làm đấy bị lớn
Chán luôn cho bộ nhớ
em thấy
cái mạng ah Đúng rồi thế mà này nó rất
là lớn truyền vào tận 10000 inch nhà mày
ông làm kiểu ngày nó sẽ bị nặng như là
mấy ông sẽ phải cắt ra không ghé lại
liên quan việc in suốt vào trong máy que
nhiều quá cùng lúc nên nó bị chàm thì
mày ông có thể là fuik ở đây
a a a d Trăng nghĩa 77 lại một mày lấy 1
chợ
hoa cả đây ông sẽ làm mà ông giải phóng
bộ nhớ luôn ít Cola y phần trăm
a1000
à à
anh bằng bằng bằng không nhận ngày nghĩa
chia hết cho 1000 thì mình sẽ in sơ vào
như này sau đó khi giải phóng
giải phóng luôn cái mạng này để cho nó
nhẹ bớt dữ liệu đi cứ thấy nó sẽ không
bị
có gì đấy
à à
ờ ờ
xin lỗi phoneky
the four key bị lỗi
không có đi ID
ăn gì đây mạng này này làm sao ra lỗi
nhỉ
xe đẩy ra một cái đi ngang sách comedy
show truyền ở đây
xin lỗi này hãy Insert cái thằng này
em yêu sub-company trước xuất này sau
làm sao Lỗi nhỉ
đấy à
Ừ vợ tôi tí Đợi tôi một tí
Xe tôi chạy tách luôn béo mà tôi thường
này đôi khi không chắc mình muốn tay thì
tôi sẽ làm đấy ạ
à à
ngày mà mình sẽ chạy cái á Ở đây là web
mũi rồi đúng không web Mùi rồi việc làm
Xem test
Loco đâu có hót
ý là không không ở sai đấy
- tôn hữu với thằng a Company sao ý
à à
ai đâu mẹ nhớ ra Đun chi vậy
phải là noboru trẻ
à à
vì vậy mẹ ông có bị đau mày không có
thấy mày có bị đâu
được chứ
anh alo alo alo
Ê mày có bị đứng có gì à
các ngôi sao
ừ ừ
Em
hãy tìm Ôi có tại rồi
lấy để buổi sao vậy nha
Ồ sao vậy nha Đào hôm nay hơn hai tiếng
rồi Chắc là nó bị Chán cái gì đó
từ buffet cho thế
ờ ờ
Khi Người Yêu Tôi sửa cái đoạn này rồi
tôi sẽ
có thể thao đoạn này sửa nhanh thôi này
là halin đâu mà lấy ra ra Đun cái key ở
trong cái trong cái loại Android nên là
mình sẽ
mình sẽ là kiểu gọi đến á
Ừ thế kia là được rồi sẽ đẩy cốt lên cho
mấy ông chưa câu truy vấn nó sẽ thành
như này
à à
Ừ mẹ thế nào chạy đủ Ừ để chạy thủ lại
cho bé ông anh ở bây giờ chạy thì nếu mà
được thì méo lại không biết được nhanh
nhưng
Ừ Ừ thế là nó vẫn đang đâu đấy nó không
nghe được
anh ở đấy chạy Xong rồi chín phẩy năm
mươi
à Còn đo thằng kia thôi chứ biết bao
nhiêu giây nữa mày không thử thử chạy
lại thằng kia lo nhé với thằng kia nó
không nó không đo mình được anh ạ
à à
này câu truy vấn này sẽ thả nhanh hơn
tôi sẽ đẩy lên nhé
mình sẽ đẩy gọi này lên chồng với ông
tham khảo ngủ chưa ờ ờ
bố mày chắc chỉ thôi
vi phạm đấy nha Sao mấy ông nhá
Có gì tôi sẽ trả lời mấy câu hỏi buổi
sau nhé
Ừ nghỉ ngơi thôi